ya han pasado varias horas desde el
inicio de estas elecciones primarias
para decidir las listas que competirán
en las legislativas del 14 de noviembre
cuando se renovarán en argentina la
mitad más o menos de la cámara de
diputados y aproximadamente un tercio
del senado la votación comenzó a las 8
de la mañana en centros de votación como
el que se encuentra a mis espaldas en
muchos casos son escuelas son unos
17.500 un poco más de centros de
votación 20 por ciento más que en otras
ocasiones previendo la situación de
pandemia para que se distribuyan más los
votantes en diferentes centros en el
inicio hubo algunos reportes de demoras
en los centros de votación fuera de eso
es una elección normal que se está
desarrollando en forma tranquila
concluirá la votación aproximadamente a
las 18 horas de argentina y se esperan
los primeros resultados para las 23
horas